The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: All right.
Today we start a new section
in advanced data structures,
and it's data structures
for memory hierarchy.
So the idea here is while
almost all data structures think
about memory as a flat thing.
And in the RAM model,
you've got a giant array.
You can access the i-th
element in your giant array
in constant time.
The memory hierarchy,
you admit the reality
of almost all computers
since, I don't know, '80s,
which have caches.
The idea is you have
your CPU connected
with a very high bandwidth
channel to a relatively
small cache, which is
connected via a relatively
narrow bandwidth channel
to a really big memory.
And in real computers,
this keeps going.
You've got level 1 cache,
then level 2 cache,
then level 3 cache maybe, then
main memory, then disk, then
network, whatever.
Usually the disk has a cache.
So you have this
very deep hierarchy,
which is typically growing
exponentially in size,
and also growing exponentially
in slowness, in latency.
So you'd like to
design data structures
that most of the time are
working at the cache level,
because that's really fast.
And as little as
possible, you'd like
to go to the deeper levels.
So we're going to define
two models for working
with memory hierarchies.
The first model is called
the external memory model.
It's also called the I/O model.
It's also called the
Disk Access Model,
I think just so that it could
be called the DAM model.
I usually call it the
external memory model.
And this is sort of
the simplest model.
It's also the most well
studied, I would say.
And it's going to relate
closely to the other models
that we're going to look at.
And the idea with the
external memory model
is, yeah, OK, a
real computer has
many levels in this hierarchy.
But let's just focus on the last
one and the next to last one,
because typically that last
one is going to be way,
way slower than all the others.
And so you really want
to minimize how many
memory transfers happen here.
So I want to count the number
of memory transfers between two
levels.
And so this model just
thinks about two levels.
I'll call them cache and disk.
We think of disk as
infinite and slow.
We think of cache as not only
fast, but infinitely fast.
It takes zero time to
access something in cache.
All we're thinking
about is how many
transfers between the left
and right have to happen.
So computation here is free.
Access over here is free.
And we just pay for this.
That's the external
memory model.
You can also think about running
time, make sure running time
is still optimal and that will
guarantee this part's good.
But usually the hard part
is to minimize this part,
minimize number of
memory transfers.
Now, to make this problem
really interesting,
we need to add one
more assumption.
And this is also the
case in practice,
that when you request--
when you transfer an
item from disk to cache,
you get not just that
item, but entire block
of items at the same speed.
So in fact, disk
we're going to think
of as divided into blocks.
Block size here is B, capital B.
Also over here, caches are
divided into blocks of size B.
And we have a limited
number of them.
We're going to suppose we
have M over B cache lines
they're usually called
at the cache level.
And so the total
size of the cache
is M. M stands for memory.
Sorry.
This notation is
slightly confusing
for historical reasons,
but that's the way it is.
So B is block size.
M is cache size,
total cache size.
There's M over B
blocks of size B. Disk
has infinitely many
blocks of size B.
There's lots of
motivations for this.
But basically, the main cost
you're paying here is latency.
You have to send
a request and then
the answer has to come back.
Think of that as the disk
is far away from the CPU.
And so it takes a long time
for the request to get there
and for the data to get back.
So if you're sending
data back, you
might as well send-- it's just
as fast to send a lot of data
as a little bit of data.
In fact, typically you
set this block size
that the amount of time it
takes for data to arrive
equals the latency to
balance those two costs.
With disk it's
especially the case,
because you have this latency
of moving the disk head.
Once you move the disk
head, you might as well
read the entire track,
the entire circle of that
if you're dealing
with hard drives.
It's just as fast once
the head gets there.
OK.
So that's the model.
And so now we want to minimize
the number of block memory
transfers this happens.
And the blocks make things
a lot more interesting,
because that means
when you read an item,
you really want to use all
the items right around it
soon, before it gets
kicked out of cache.
Obviously, cache
is limited size,
so when you bring
something, you've
got to kick something out.
That's the block
replacement strategy.
In the external memory model,
you can do whatever you want.
You have full control
over this cache.
So let's see.
Let me write some
obvious bounds.
And then I'll tell you some of
the main results in this model.
So number of memory transfers
is what we care about.
And it's going to be at most
the running time on a RAM,
so this is a comparison
between two models.
At most, every operation you
do on a RAM data structure
incurs one memory transfer.
That would be the worst case.
So that's what we want to beat.
There's also a lower bound.
So this is also at least the
number of cell probes divided
by B. I think we've talked
briefly about the cell probe
model, I think in
retroactive data structures.
Cell probe model is this
model where all you count is--
you just count how
many words did I
have to read in order to do
this data structure operation?
So computation is free.
We just count number of
word reads from memory.
So it's a lower bound
on RAM data structures.
And in this model, we're only
counting memory accesses,
but where cell probes
you count word numbers,
here we're counting blocks.
And so at best, we can
improve by a factor of B.
So this is a lower bound.
This is an upper bound,
so there's roughly a slop
of a factor of B here.
We want to do closer to
this bound than this bound.
This is the obvious thing.
Want to get down to
here whenever we can.
So let me give you
some examples of that,
so sort of a bunch of basic
results in this model.
Result 0 is scanning, so
if I have an array of items
and I just want to,
say, add them all up
or do a linear scan to search
for something, anything that
involves accessing
them in order,
this will cost I guess
ceiling of N over B.
If the array has size N,
number of blocks in that array
is ceiling of N over B. And so
that's how many block accesses
it costs.
So the annoying part
here is the ceiling.
If N is smaller than B,
then this is not great.
I mean, you have to pay one
memory read, so it's optimal.
But anyway, that's scanning.
Pretty boring.
Slightly more interesting,
although not that much more
interesting, is search trees.
If you want to be able
to search for an item
in this external memory model--
in this external memory
model, what do you do?
B-trees, conveniently
named B-trees.
We want the branching
factor of a B-tree
to be B. Anything
that's theta B will do,
but exactly B is great.
If you can read all
of these pointers
and read all of these key
values, if that fits in B,
then we're happy.
So yeah, typically we assume
the branching factor here
is like B plus 1.
So in particular,
if B is 1, you still
have a branching
factor of 2, just
to make it a reasonable tree.
And so now in a
constant number of block
reads you can read all the
data you need to decide
which child pointer you follow.
You follow that child
pointer, and so it
takes log base B plus
1 of N to do a search.
This is counting
memory transfers.
So this is not as
big an improvement.
Here, we've improved by
a factor of B roughly.
Here we're improving by a
factor of basically log B.
So not as good as you might
hope to do, dividing by B,
but it turns out
this is optimal.
You need log base
B plus 1 of N to do
a search in comparison model.
In the same way, you
need log base 2 of N time
to do a search in
the comparison model,
in this model you
need log base B of N.
Let me talk a little bit
about the proof of that.
It's a pretty simple
information theoretic argument.
So we prove this lower bound.
The idea is the following.
You want to figure
out among N items
here where your item fits.
Let's say it fits right here.
So you want to know it's between
this element and this element.
How many bits of
information is that?
Well, there's I guess N plus
1 different outcomes of where
your item could fit.
If you allow it to exactly
match, it's maybe twice that.
But there's theta N
options for your answer.
And so if you take logs, that
is log N bits of information.
And this is how
you normally show
that you need log N comparison.
You need log N comparisons
because each comparison
could at most give you one
bit of information, yes or no.
And there's log N bits to
get, so that's the lower bound
in binary search.
But now we're in this
model where we're not
counting comparisons,
even though we're
in the comparison model.
We're counting number
of block transfers.
So when I read in some data,
I get B items from my array,
or from something.
So when I do a block read, all
I can do in the comparison model
is compare my item to
everything that I read,
so you might as well
compare all of them.
But the information you learn
is only log B plus 1 bits,
because what you learn is among
these B items, where do I fit?
And in the best case,
that is log of B
plus 1 bits of information.
It could be worse, if these
guys are not well distributed
among your N items.
It's at most that.
And so you take the ratio
and you need log N over log B
plus 1 block reads.
And that's log
base B plus 1 of N.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Why is that you
learn log B plus 1 bits when
you [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIK DEMAINE: All right.
So the claim is, in
the comparison model,
you compare your item
to everyone in here.
But if your array is presorted,
then all you're learning is--
I mean, information
theoretically,
all your learning is where your
item fits among these B items.
So there's order B options of
where you fit, and so only log
B bits of information there.
You might consider
this a vague argument.
You can do a more
formal version of it.
But I like the information
theoretic perspective.
Cool.
So that's the best thing you
can do for search in this model.
Now, you might also wonder
about insertions and deletions.
B-trees support insertions
and deletions in log
base B plus 1 of N time,
but that is not optimal.
We can do better.
So for example, if
you want to sort,
the right answer for
sorting is this crazy bound.
N over B, which is
really good, that's
linear time in this model, times
log base M over B of N over B.
This is a slight-- this is
roughly log base M of N.
The over B's don't make
too big a difference.
So this is an improvement.
Normally sorting takes
N log N with a base 2.
We're improving the base of the
log to M over B instead of 2.
And we're improving the overall
running time by a factor of B.
So this is actually a
really big improvement.
We're going faster than the
RAM time divided by a B,
because to sort in
the cell probe model
just takes linear time.
You read all the data.
You sort it.
You put it back.
So we can't quite get N over
B, but we get this log factor.
So this is really good.
And it's something that would
not result from using B-trees.
This is a little funny,
because in regular RAM model,
if you insert everything into
a balanced binary search tree,
then do an in order
traversal, that's
an optimal sorting algorithm.
It gives you N log N.
Here, it's not optimal.
You throw everything
into a B-tree,
you get N times log
base B of N. So there's
two things that are bad.
One is that the base of
the log is slightly off.
It's B versus M over B.
That's not so big a deal.
The big thing is it's
N over B versus N.
We don't want to pay N. We want
to pay N over B. There's also
a matching lower bound in the
comparison model, which we will
not cover here.
By next lecture, we'll know
how to do sorting optimally.
First, I want to tell
you about a bunch
of different ways or different
problems and results.
So a funny problem,
which actually does
arise in practice, but
it's interesting just
to think about,
instead of sorting--
sorting is I give you an array.
I don't know what order it's in.
You have to find the
right order and then
put it into the right order.
There's an easier problem,
which is called permuting.
I give you an array.
I give you a permutation
that I'd like to do.
I just want you to
move the items around.
So you don't need to do any
comparisons to get here.
I tell you what the order is.
You just have to
physically move the items.
This is harder than it
sounds, because when you read,
you read blocks of items
in the original order.
And so it's hard to just do
an arbitrary permutation.
And there's two
obvious algorithms.
One is you could
sort your items.
So you could go to
every item in order
and just write down its desired
number in the new permutation,
write down the permutation.
Then run a sorting algorithm.
That will take N over B log
base M over B of N over B.
Or the other obvious algorithm
is to take the first item,
put it where it belongs in the
array, take the second item,
put it where it
belongs in the array,
in a new copy of the array.
And that will take at
most N memory transfers,
each one a completely
separate memory transfer.
And the claim is
the optimal thing
to do is the min of those two.
So you just check
how does N and B
and M compare, do the better
of the two algorithms.
Again, there's a lower bound.
In a model called the
indivisible model,
which is assuming that
each word of your data
doesn't get cut into subwords.
So this is assuming--
the lower bound assuming
your words do not get cut up.
I believe it's still unsolved
whether you could do better
otherwise.
The last result in this
model I wanted to talk about
is called buffer trees.
Buffer trees are pretty cool.
They're essentially
a dynamic version
of sorting, which
is what we lack--
what B-trees do not give you.
So they achieve
the sorting bound
divided by N per operation,
so this is optimal.
I haven't told you what
the operations are.
The amount is amortized.
It has to be amortized,
because this bound is typically
little o of 1.
Think of this as 1 over
B. There's a log factor.
But assuming that log factor is
smaller than B, which is often
the case, this is
in order 1 over B.
It's a little o of 1 cost,
which is a little fun.
But of course, every
real cost is an integer.
It's an integer number
of block transfers.
But amortized, you can
get a little o of 1 bound.
And what it lets you do is
delayed queries and batch
updates.
So I can do an insert
and I can a delete.
I can do many of them.
And then I can do a query
against the current data
structure.
I want to know, I don't know,
the successor of an item.
But I don't get the
answer right then.
It's delayed.
The query will sit there.
Eventually the
data structure will
decide to give me an answer.
Or it may just never
give me an answer.
But then there's a new operation
at the end, which is flush,
which is give me all the
answers to all the questions
that I asked.
And the flush takes
this much time.
So if you do N operations
and then say flush,
then it doesn't
take any extra time.
It's going to cost
one sort of pass
through the entire data
structure, one sorting step.
Yeah.
The one thing you can get for
free is a zero-cost find min.
All right.
So buffer tree, you can do
find min instantaneously.
It maintains the
min all the time.
So this lets you do
a priority queue.
You can do insert and delete
min in this much time online.
But if you want to do
other kinds of queries,
then they're slow to answer.
You get the answer much later.
So this is a dynamic
version of sorting.
It lets you do
sorting in particular.
It let's you do priority
queues, other great things.
We will see not
quite a buffer tree
but another data structure
achieving similar bounds
in the next lecture.
Today's lecture
is actually going
to be about B-trees, which
seems kind of boring,
because we already
know how to do B-trees.
But we're going to do them
in another model, which
is the cache-oblivious model.
So let me tell you
about that model.
All right.
So the cache-oblivious
model is much newer.
It's from 1999.
And it's from MIT
originally, Charles Leiserson
and his students
invented it back then,
in the context of
6406, I believe.
And it's almost the same as
this external memory model.
There's one change, which is
that the algorithm doesn't
know what B or M is.
Now, this is both awkward
and cool at the same time.
So the assumption is that
the computer looks like this.
The algorithm has no--
and the algorithm
knows that fact,
but it doesn't know what the
parameters of the cache are.
Doesn't know how the
memory is blocked.
Now, as a consequence, it cannot
manually say, read this block,
write this block.
It can't decide which
block to kick out.
This is going to be more
like a typical algorithm.
I mean, the algorithm will look
like a regular RAM algorithm.
It's going to say
read this word,
write this word to memory,
do an addition, whatever.
So algorithm looks
like a RAM algorithm.
But the analysis is
going to be different.
So this is convenient,
because algorithms--
I mean, how you implement
an algorithm becomes
much clearer in this model.
And this is-- now we're going
to assume that the cache is
maintained automatically.
In particular, the way
that blocks are replaced
becomes automatic.
So the assumption is when
you read a word from memory,
the entire block comes over.
You just don't know
how much data that is.
And when something
gets kicked out,
the entire block gets kicked
out and written to memory.
But you don't get
to see how that's
happening, because you don't
know anything about B or M.
We need to assume something
about this replacement
strategy.
And in the
cache-oblivious model,
we assume that it is optimal.
This is an offline
notion, saying
what block we're
going to kick out
is the one that will be
used farthest in the future,
so this is very hard to
implement in practice,
because you need a crystal ball.
But good news is, you
could use something
like LRU, Least Recently Used,
kick that guy out, or even
a very simple algorithm,
first in, first out.
The most recent--
the oldest block
that you brought in is
the one that you kick out.
These are actually
very close to optimal.
They're constant
competitive against or given
a cache of twice the size.
So this is from the early
days of competitive analysis.
It says if I compare offline
optimal with a cache size M
versus--
or let's say offline
optimal with a cache size
M over 2, versus
LRU or FIFO, which
are online algorithms
on a cache of size M,
then this cost will be at
most I think twice this cost.
Now, the good news is, you
look at all these bounds,
you change M by a factor
of 2, nothing changes.
Assuming everything is
at least some constant,
and M and B are not
super super close,
then changing M by a factor of
2 doesn't affect these bounds.
These ones don't even have M in
them, so it's not a big deal.
So we're going to assume
this basically for analysis.
It's not really that big a deal.
You could also analyze
with these models.
The point is
they're all the same
within a constant factor for
the algorithms we care about.
What other fun things?
If you have a good,
cache-oblivious algorithm,
it's good simultaneously
for all B and M.
That's the consequence.
So whereas B-trees for
example, need to know B,
they need to have the right
branching factor for your value
of B, the cache-oblivious
model, you have to have--
your data structure
has to be correct,
has to be optimized for all
values of B and all values of M
simultaneously.
So this has some
nice side effects.
In particular, you
essentially adapt
to different values of B and
M. So two nice side effects
of that are that if you have a
multi-level memory hierarchy,
each level has its
own B and its own M.
If you use a
cache-oblivious algorithm
and all of those caches are
maintained automatically
using one of these
strategies, then
you optimize the number of--
maybe I should draw a picture.
Here's a multi-level
memory hierarchy.
You optimize the number
of memory transfers
between these two levels.
You optimize the number
of memory transfers
between these two levels,
and between these two levels.
So you optimize everything.
Each of them has some--
if you just think of this as
one big level versus this level
or versus all the
levels to the right,
then that has some B
and some M. And you're
minimizing the number of
memory transfers here.
Also, if B and M are changing,
lots of situations for that.
If you have multiple programs
running at the same time,
then your cache size
might effectively
go down if they're
really running
in parallel on the same
computer, or pseudo-parallel.
Block size could change.
If you think of a disk
and your block size
is the size of your track,
then closer to the center,
the tracks are smaller.
Closer to the rim of the
disk then blocks are bigger.
All these things basically
in the cache-oblivious model,
you don't care, because
it will just work.
Now, there's no
nice formalization
of adapting to changing
values of B and M.
That's kind of an
open problem to make
explicit what that means.
But we're going to assume in
the cache-oblivious models you
have one fixed B, one fixed
M, analyze relative to that.
But of course, that analysis
applies simultaneously to all
B's and all M's.
And so it feels like you adapt
optimally, whatever that means.
In some sense, the
most surprising thing
about the cache-oblivious
world is that it's possible.
You can work in this
model and get basically
all of these results.
So let me go over these results.
So in the cache-oblivious model,
of course scans are still good.
Scans didn't assume anything
about block size here,
except in the analysis.
Scanning was just
a sequential read.
In general, we can do
constant number of scans.
Some of them can go to left.
Some of them could
go to the right.
Some of them could be reading.
Some of them could be writing.
That's the general form of scan.
But all of that will take
order N over B ceiling.
OK.
Search.
This is what we're going
to be focused on today.
You can achieve order log
base B plus 1 of N search,
insert, and delete.
Just like B-trees, but
without knowing what B is.
We're going to do
most of that today.
What's next?
Sorting.
Sorting, you can
do the same bound.
That we'll see next lecture.
OK.
Next is permuting.
Here there's actually a
negative result, which
is that you can't do the min.
It doesn't say exactly
what you can do.
In particular, we
can certainly permute
as quickly as we can sort.
And we can permute--
we can achieve this
min in a weird sense,
in that we can achieve N and
we can achieve the sorting
bound for permutation in
the cache-oblivious model,
either one, but
not both with min
around them, because to
know which one to apply,
you need to know how
B and M relate to N,
and you don't here.
And so there's a
lower bound saying
you really can't
achieve this bound,
even up to constant factors.
But it doesn't explicitly
say anything more than that.
So a little awkward.
Fortunately, permuting
isn't that big a deal.
And most of the time
the sorting bound
is much faster than the
end bound, so not so bad.
But slightly awkward.
So there's some
things you can't do.
This was the first negative
result in cache-oblivious.
Another fun negative result
is actually in search trees.
You might ask, what is
this constant factor here
in front of the log
base B plus 1 of N?
And for B-trees, the constant
factor is essentially 1.
You get 1 times log
base B plus 1 of N.
In cache-oblivious
world, you can
prove that 1 is unattainable
and the best possible
constant factor is log base
2 of e, which was like 1.44.
So that is the right
answer for the constant.
Today we'll get a
constant here of 4.
This is for search.
But 4 has since been improved
to 1.44, so a tiny separation
there between cache-oblivious
and external memory.
Let's see.
One more thing.
Continuing over here
is priority queue.
Cache-oblivious we can
do in the optimal time
1 over B log base M
over B of N over B.
Only catch with
that result is it
assumes something called
the tall cache assumption.
Let's see what I
want to say here.
We'll say M is omega B
to the 1 plus epsilon.
That's an ugly-looking omega.
Certainly M is at least B.
If you have one cache line,
you have M equal
B. But we'd like
M to be a little bit bigger than
B. We'd like the cache to be--
if M was at least B squared,
then the height of the cache
would be at least as big as
the width of the cache, hence
tall cache.
But we don't even need
M equal to B squared.
Just M to the--
M equaling B to the
1.001 would be enough.
Then you can get this result.
And there's a theorem that
shows for cache-oblivious
you need to assume this
tall cache assumption.
You cannot achieve
this bound without it.
But this is usually true for
real caches, so life is good.
All right.
So that's a quick summary
of cache-oblivious results.
Any questions about those?
Then we proceed into achieving
search trees log base B of N
performance cache-obliviously.
Make it interesting,
because external memory,
we already know how to
do it with a B-tree.
So we did both models,
cache-oblivious B-tree
is what remain.
This was the first result
in cache-oblivious data
structures.
I'm going to start with
the static problem.
Cache-oblivious
static search trees.
This was actually in a MEng
thesis here by Harold Prokop.
So the idea is very simple.
We can't use B-trees because
we don't know what B is,
so we'll use binary
search trees.
Those have served
us well so far.
So let's use a balanced
binary search tree.
And because it's
static, might as well
assume it's a perfect
balanced binary search tree.
Let me draw one over here.
I'll draw my favorite one.
So how do you search in
a binary search tree?
Binary search.
Our algorithm is fixed.
So the only
flexibility we have is
how we map this tree into the
sequential order in memory.
Memory is an array.
So for each of
these nodes, we get
to assign some
order, some position
in the array of memory.
And then each of these
child pointers, that
changes where they point to.
And now
cache-obliviously, you're
going to follow some
root to leaf path.
You don't know which one.
All of them are visiting
nodes in some order,
which looks pretty random.
In the array of
memory, it's going
to be some sequence like this.
We would like the
number of blocks
that contain those nodes to
be relatively small somehow.
So that's the hard part.
Now, you could try level order.
You could try in order,
pre order, post order.
All of them fail.
The right order is something
called van Emde Boas order.
So let's say there are N nodes.
What we're going to
do is carve the tree
at the middle level of edges.
So we have a tree like this.
We divide in the middle.
Leaves us with the top
part and many bottom parts.
There's going to be about
square root of N nodes
in each of these little
triangles, roughly speaking.
The number of
triangles down here
is going to be roughly
square root of N--
I think I have written here
square root of N plus 1.
It's a little overestimate,
because I multiply those two
numbers, it's bigger than N.
But it's roughly that.
If there were root
N nodes up here,
then there would be square
root of N plus 1 children,
and square root of N
plus 1 things down there.
So roughly, root N different
things, each of size root N.
Then what we do is
recursively lay out
all those triangles of
size roughly squared of N,
and then concatenate.
It's a very simple idea.
Let's apply it to this tree.
So I split in the middle
level and I recursively
lay out this triangle up here--
draw it as a box.
Then I recursively lay out this.
Then I recursively lay out
this and this and this.
So up here, I mean,
to lay this out,
I would again split
in the middle level,
lay out this piece, so this
guy will go first, then
this one, then this one.
Now I'll go over and recursively
do this, so it's 4, 5, 6.
Then this one, 7, 8, 9,
10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15.
That is the order in
which I store the nodes.
And I claim that's a good order.
For example, if B equals
3, this looks really good,
because then all of these
nodes are in the first block.
And so I get to choose which
of these four children trees
I should look at.
I mean, I happen to go
here and then maybe here.
I look at those two nodes,
look at their keys to decide,
oh, I should go
into this branch.
But I only pay one
memory transfer
to look at all those nodes.
So this looks like a tree
tuned for B equals 3.
But it turns out it's tuned
for all B's simultaneously,
if we do this recursively.
It's hard to draw
a small example
where you see all
the B's at once,
but that's the best I can do.
OK.
Let's analyze this thing.
So the order of
the nodes is clear.
If you know what the van
Emde Boas data structure is,
then you know why
it's called this.
Otherwise, see lecture
10 or so in the future.
Forget exactly where
we're covering it.
So this order was not
invented by van Emde Boas,
but it looks very similar
to something else that
was invented by van Emde
Boas, so we call it that.
But that's the name
of a guy, Peter.
Analysis.
Order's clear.
The algorithm is clear.
We follow our root to leaf path.
What we claim is any root to
leaf path and any value of B,
the number of blocks visited
is order log base B of N.
So to do that, in the analysis
we get to know what B is.
The algorithm didn't know.
Algorithm here doesn't know
B and doesn't need to know B.
But to analyze it, to prove
an order log base B of N,
we need to know what B is.
So while the algorithm
recurses all the way down,
keeps dividing these blocks
into smaller and smaller pieces,
we're going to look
at a particular level
of that recursion.
I'm going to call that
a level of detail.
Say I call it straddling B.
So my picture is going
to be the following.
These little triangles are
going to be size less than B.
But these big triangles are
size greater than or equal to B.
OK.
At some level of recursion
that happens, by monotonicity,
I guess.
I could keep going.
I mean, this tree is going
to have substantial height.
I don't really know
how tall it is,
or that's sort of
the central question.
Draw in some pointers here.
But just look at--
if you subdivide all
the big triangles
until you get to these
small triangles that
are size less than B,
then you stop recursing.
Now, the algorithm, of course,
will recursively lay that out.
But what we know, we
recursively lay things out
and then we concatenate, meaning
the recursive layouts remain
consecutive.
We never like
interleave two layouts.
So however this thing is laid
out, we don't really care,
because at that point it's
going to be stored in memory,
which is this giant array.
It's going to be stored
in interval of size
less than B. So at worst,
where are the block boundaries?
Maybe draw that in red.
Block boundaries are size B. We
don't know exactly how they're
interspersed.
Let's say these are
the block boundaries.
So it could be that this little
subarray falls into two blocks,
but at most two blocks.
So the little triangles
of size less than B
live in at most
two memory blocks.
So to visit each of
these little triangles,
we only spend two
memory reads at most.
So all that's left is to
count how many of those
little triangles do we need to
visit on a root to leaf path?
I claim that's going
to be log base B of N.
So I guess the first question
is, what is the height of one
of these little triangles?
Well, we start with
a tree of height
log N. Then we divide it in
half and we divide it in half
and divide it in half.
And we take floors and
ceilings, whatever.
But we repeatedly divide
the height in half.
And we stop whenever the
number of nodes in there
is less than B. So that
means the height is going
to be theta log B.
In fact, it's going
to be in the range
1/2 log B to log B,
probably with a paren that way.
Doesn't really matter, because
you stop as soon as you hit B.
You're dividing the
height in half repeatedly.
You might overshoot
by at most a half.
That's it.
So height is log B.
So if we look along
a root to leaf path,
each of these
things we visit, we
make vertical progress
log B, theta log B.
And the total vertical progress
we need to make is log N,
and so it's log N
divided by log B.
So I guess 4 times log
N, 2 log N over log B.
Triangles, we reach a leaf.
It's total progress we
need to make divided by 1/2
log B here, progress
per triangle.
So we get 2 times log base B of
N. And then for each triangle,
we have to pay 2
memory reads, so
this implies at most 4 log
base B of N memory transfers.
And I implicitly assumed
here that B is not 1.
Otherwise, need a B plus
1 here to be interesting.
So long as B isn't 1,
then it doesn't matter.
OK.
So that's the log base B of
N analysis, actually really
simple.
Essentially what
we're doing here
is binary searching on B in a
kind of weird way, using divide
and conquer and recursion.
So we say, well, maybe
B is the whole thing,
then B equals N. Then we
don't have to do anything.
Everything fits in a block.
Otherwise, let's imagine
dividing here and supposing
B is root N, and then
we need two accesses.
But B might be smaller than
that, so we keep recursing,
keep going down.
And because we're dividing
in half each time--
sorry.
We're not binary
searching on B. We're
binary searching on log
B, which is the height
of a tree with B nodes in it.
And that's exactly what
we can afford to do.
And conveniently, it's
all we need to do,
because to get log
base B of N correct,
you only need to
get log B correct up
to a constant factor.
All right.
Now, that was the easy part.
Now the hard part is
to make this dynamic.
This is where
things get exciting.
This works fine
for a static tree.
And this is how we do search.
But we can't do inserts and
deletes in this world easily.
But I'll show you how
to do it nonetheless.
So this is what's called
a cache-oblivious B-tree.
We're going to do
it in five steps.
And the first step,
unfortunately,
is delayed until next lecture,
so I need a black box.
It's a very useful black box.
It's actually one that we've
briefly talked about before,
I think in the time travel.
If you remember, in
time travel there
was one black box, which
we still haven't seen
but we will do finally
next lecture, which
was you can insert
into a linked list
and then given two
items in the linked list
know which one comes
before which other one
in constant time per operation.
Closely related to that is
a slightly different problem
called order file maintenance.
Here's what it lets you do.
You can store N elements,
N words in specified order,
so just like it's a linked list.
But we don't store
it as a linked list.
We want to store it in
an array of linear size.
So there's going to be some
blank spots in this array.
We've got N items, an array
of size, say 2N or 1.1 times
N, anything like
that will suffice.
The rest, we call them
gaps, gaps in the array.
And the updates-- so this is
physically what you have to do.
You can change this
set of elements
by either deleting an element
or inserting an element
between two given elements.
So this is just like
the linked list updates.
I can delete somebody
from a linked list.
I can insert a new item
in between two given
items in the linked list.
But now it has to be stored in
a physical array of linear size.
Now, we can't do this
in constant time.
But what we can do is
move elements around.
OK.
So let me draw a picture.
So maybe we have
some elements here.
They could be in sorted
order, maybe not.
There are some gaps in between.
I didn't mention it, but all
gaps will have constant size.
So this will be
constant-sized gaps.
And we're able to do things
like insert a new item
right after 42.
Let's say we insert 12.
So 12, we could put it
right here, no problem.
Now maybe we say insert
right after 42 the number 6.
And we're like, oh,
there's no room to put 6.
So I've got to move some stuff.
Maybe I move 12 over here
and then I put 6 here.
And then I say, OK, now insert
right after 42 the number 7.
And you're like, uh-oh.
I could move these guys over one
and then put 7 here, and so on.
Obvious algorithm to do this.
Takes linear time, linear
number of shifts in order
to do one insertion.
Claim is you can do an insertion
in log squared amortized.
It's pretty cool.
So worst case,
you'll still going
to need to shift everybody.
But just leaving
constant-sized gaps
will be enough to reduce
amortized costs to log squared.
And this is conjectured
optimal, though no one
knows how to prove that.
And that's order
file maintenance.
Now, we're going to assume
this is a black box.
Next lecture, we'll
actually do it.
But I want to first
show you how it
lets us get cache-oblivious
dynamic B-trees.
Log base B of N,
insert, delete, search.
OK.
We're going to use an
ordered file maintenance data
structure to store our keys,
just stick them in there.
Now, this is good--
well, it's really not
good for anything,
although it's a starting point.
It can do updates in
log squared of N--
I didn't mention this part--
in a constant number of scans.
So think of these as
this kind of shift.
I have to scan left to
right, copy 23 to the left,
42 to the left, and so on.
Scans are things we
know how to do fast in N
over B memory transfers.
So if you're going
to do log squared--
if you're going to update
an interval log squared guys
using constant
number of scans, this
will take log squared N
over B memory transfers.
Not quite the bound we want.
We want log base B of N.
This could be larger or
smaller than log base B of N.
It depends how big B is.
But don't worry
about it for now.
This is still-- at
least it's poly log.
Updates are kind
of vaguely decent.
We'll improve them later.
On the other hand, search
is really bad here.
I mean, we're
maintaining the items--
I didn't mention it, but we
will actually maintain the items
in sorted order.
So yeah, you could
do a binary search.
But binary search is really
bad cache-obliviously,
because most of the
time you'll be visiting
a new block until the very end.
So binary search-- this
is a fun exercise--
is log N minus log B. We
want log N divided by log B.
So we can't use binary search.
We need to use van Emde
Boas layouts, this thing.
So we just plug these together.
We take this static
search tree and stick it
on top of an ordered file
maintenance data structure.
So here we have a van Emde
Boas layout static tree
on top of this thing,
which is an ordered file.
And we have cross-linking.
Really here we have gaps.
And we don't store
the gaps up here.
Or do we?
Yeah, sure.
We do, actually.
Store them all.
Put it all in there.
All right.
I'm going to have an
actual example here.
Let's do it 3 slash
7, 9 slash 16, 21, 42.
OK.
Cross-links between.
I won't draw all of them.
Then we store all the
data up here as well.
And then the internal
nodes here are
going to store the max
of the whole subtree.
So here the max is 3.
Here the max is 9,
16, 42, 42, and 9.
If I store the max of every
subtree, then at the root.
If I want to decide should I
go left or should I go right,
I look at the max
of the left subtree
and that will let
me know whether I
should go left or right.
So now I can do binary search.
I do a search up here.
I want to do a search,
I search the tree.
This thing is laid
out just like this.
And so we pay log base B of
N to search up here, plus 1,
if you want.
And then we get to a
key and we're done.
That's all we wanted to know.
So search is now good.
Updates, two problems.
One is that updating just
this bottom part is slow.
Second problem is if I
change the bottom thing,
now I have to change
the top thing.
But let's look at
that part first.
It's not so bad to update--
I mean, this structure stays
the same, unless N doubles.
Then we rebuild the
entire data structure.
But basically, this
thing will stay the same.
It's just data is moving
around in this array.
And we have to
update which values
are stored in this structure.
The layout of the
structure, the order
of the nodes, that
all stays fixed.
It's just the numbers
that are being
written in here that change.
That's the cool idea.
So that's step 2.
Let's go to step 3.
I actually kind of wanted
that exact picture.
That's OK.
I need to specify
how updates are done.
So let's say I want
to do an insertion.
If I want to insert a new
key, I search for the key.
Maybe it fits between 7 and 9.
Then I do the insertion
in the bottom structure
in the ordered file.
So we want to insert 8.
These guys move around.
Then I have to propagate
that information up here.
And the key thing
I want to specify
is an update does a search.
Then it updates
the ordered file.
That's going to take
log squared N over B.
And then we want to
propagate changes
into the tree in post-order,
post-order traversal.
That's the one thing
I wanted to specify,
because it actually matters in
what order I update the item.
So for example, suppose
I move 9 to the right
and then I insert 8 here.
So then this thing--
let's do it, what changes
in that situation.
9 will change to
an 8 here, which
means this value has
to change to an 8
and this value needs
to change to an 8.
And this one I can't
quite update yet,
because I need to
do the other tree.
So here I change
this value to a 9.
This one doesn't
change, so this is OK.
This is OK.
Just taking the maxes
as I propagate up.
So the red things are the
nodes that I touch and compute
the maxes of.
And the order I did it was
a post-order traversal.
I need to do a post-order
traversal in order
to compute maxes.
I need to know what
the max of this subtree
is and this subtree before I can
re-compute the max of the root.
So it's really the
obvious algorithm.
Now, the interesting
part is the analysis.
So searches we've
already analyzed.
We don't need to
do anything there.
That's log base B of N.
But updates are the
interesting thing to analyze.
And again we're going to look
at the level of detail that
straddles B, just like before.
So let me draw a good picture.
I'm going to draw it
slightly differently
from how I drew it last time.
OK.
What I'm drawing
here is actually
the bottom of the tree.
So a real tree is like this.
And I'm looking at
the bottom, where
the leaves are, because
I care about where
I connect to this ordered file.
So there's the ordered
file at the bottom.
And I'm refining each
triangle recursively
until they're size
less than B. They're
going to be somewhere
between root B and B.
These big triangles
are bigger than B. OK.
So that's where I want
to look at things.
Now, when we update
in the ordered file,
we have this theorem.
It says you move
elements in an interval.
So what changes is an interval.
The interval has size
log squared N amortized.
So we are updating
some interval here,
maybe something like this.
And so all of these
items change, let's say.
Now, this is not
going to be too big.
It's going to be log
square N amortized.
And all of the
ancestors of those nodes
have to be updated, potentially.
So all these guys are
going to get updated.
Some of this tree, this
path, all of this stuff
is going to get updated,
some of this stuff,
the path up to here.
The path up to the root
gets updated, in general,
and all these nodes get touched.
Now, I claim that's cheap, no
more expensive than updating
down here.
Let's prove that.
OK.
First issue is, in what order
do I visit the nodes here?
I want to think about
this post-order.
Maybe I'll use another
color to draw that.
So let's say we start
by updating this guy.
We update this value.
Then we go--
I'm doing a post-order
traversal, this tree.
Once I've completely
finished here,
I can go up here, maybe go up
here, visit over down this way,
fix all the maxes here.
Then I go up, fix
all the maxes here,
fix all the maxes, the maxes.
When I come up, then I can fix
the maxes up here, and so on.
OK.
Think about that order.
If you just look at
the big picture, which
is which triangles are
we visiting, what we do
is we visit this triangle, then
this one, then this triangle,
then this one, then this
triangle, then this one.
I guess this is
the better picture.
This triangle, left one,
this triangle, next child,
this parent, next child,
this parent, next child.
And when we're done, we go
over to the next big triangle.
Within a big
triangle, we alternate
between two small triangles.
As long as we have
four blocks of cache,
this will be good,
because there's
at most two blocks for
this little triangle,
this little triangle.
So jumping back and
forth between these
is basically free.
So we assume-- white chalk.
We assume that we have at
least four blocks of cache.
Post-order traversal alternates
between two little triangles.
So this part is free.
The only issue is, how
many little triangles
do I need to load overall?
Sorry.
I should say I'm just looking
at the little triangles
in the bottom two levels.
So this is in the
bottom two levels.
Sorry.
I forgot to mention that.
As soon as you go outside
the bottom big triangle,
let's not think about it yet.
Worry about that later.
So just looking at these
bottom two levels that I drew,
we're just doing
this alternation.
And so the only issue is,
how many little triangles
do I have to load?
So there could be these guys.
These guys are good, because
I'm touching all these nodes.
The number of nodes
here was bigger than B,
so if I take this divided
by B in the ceiling,
the ceiling doesn't hurt me,
because the overall size is
bigger than B.
These guys I have to be
a little bit careful.
Here the ceiling might
hurt me, because I only
read some of these nodes.
It may be much less
than B. It could
be as low as root B. I divide
by B, take the ceiling, I get 1,
so I have to pay 1 at the
beginning, 1 at the end.
But in between, I
get to divide by B.
So the number of little
triangles in the bottom two
levels that I visit is going to
be 1 plus log squared N over B
amortized.
The size of the interval
is log squared N amortized,
so this would be if I'm perfect.
But I get a plus 1 because
of various ceilings.
And also, the number
of blocks is the same,
because each of these
little triangles
fits inside at most two blocks.
So it's going to be order 1
plus log squared N over B.
OK.
So I can touch all
those in this much time,
because I assume that I can
alternate between two of them
quickly.
And once I finish one
of these leaf blocks,
I never touch it again, so I
visit each block essentially
only once as long as
my cache is this big.
Cool.
So that deals with
the bottom two levels.
I claim the bottom two
levels only pay this.
And we were already paying that
to update the ordered file,
so it's no worse.
Now, there's the levels above
this one that we can't see.
I claim that's also OK.
Sorry.
Also need number of memory
transfers is equal to that.
OK.
One more part of the argument.
Levels above the bottom two.
Nice thing about the
levels above the bottom two
is there aren't
too many triangles.
All right.
Well, there aren't too
many nodes involved.
Let's see.
So down here, there were
like log squared N nodes.
There was a lot of nodes.
Once I go up two levels,
how many of these nodes
can there be, these roots?
Well, it was log
squared N at the bottom.
And then I basically shaved
off a factor of B here,
so the number of these roots
is at most log squared N
over B. That's small.
For those nodes, I could
afford to do an entire memory
transfer for every single node.
So the number of nodes
that need updating--
these are ancestors--
is order log squared
N over B. That's the number
of leaves down there.
At some point, you reach
the common ancestor
of those leaves.
That tree-- so here,
draw a big picture.
Here's the bottom two layers.
We're shaving that off.
Up here, the number of nodes
here, these roots that we're
dealing with, that's the
log squared N over B.
So if we build a
tree on those nodes,
total number of nodes
in here is only log
squared N over B times 2,
because it's a binary tree.
But then there's also
these nodes up here.
This is potentially log N nodes.
So number of nodes
that need updating
is at most this plus log
N. So what's going on here
is we first analyzed
the bottom two layers.
That was OK because of
this ordering thing,
that we're only dealing
with two triangles at once
and therefore we pay
this size divided by B,
log squared N over B.
Then there's the common
ancestors of those nodes.
That forms a little binary tree
of size log squared N over B.
For these nodes,
this triangle up
here, we can afford to pay one
memory transfer for every node,
so we don't care that we're
efficient up here, which is--
I mean, well, let's not
worry about whether we are.
It doesn't matter.
So for these nodes, we pay at
most one memory transfer each.
And so we pay at most log
squared N over B for them.
That's fine, because we
already paid that much.
And finally, we have
to pay for these nodes
up here, which are from the
common ancestors of these guys
up to the root.
That has length at most
log N. Could be smaller
if this was a big interval.
So for these guys, we pay
order log base B of N. Why?
Because this is a
root to node path.
And this is the static analysis.
We already know that
following a root to node path
we pay at most log base B of N.
So we pay log base
B of N plus log
squared N over B for this, plus
log squared N over B for this,
plus log squared N over
B for the ordered file.
So overall running
time for an update
is log base B of N plus
log squared N over B.
We actually paid log
base B of N twice,
once to do the initial search.
I said an update first
has to search for the key.
Then it updates the order file.
That's where we've paid the
first log squared N over B.
And then to propagate all
the changes up the tree,
we pay log squared N
over B for this part,
and then another log base
B of N for this part.
OK.
That's updates with a bad bound.
It turns out we're almost there.
So at this point we
have searches optimal,
because searches are just
searching through the van Emde
Boas thing.
That's log base B of N.
Updates, not quite optimal.
I mean not quite matching
a B-tree, I should say,
because it's not an optimal
bound we're aiming for.
We're just aiming for B-trees.
We'd want to get this
bound, same as searching.
But we have this
extra term, which
if B is small, for
example if B is log N,
this term will be
bigger than this one.
The breakpoint is when B
equals log n times log log N.
So for small B, we're not happy.
And we want to be happy
for all B's simultaneously.
So I want to fix this.
We're going to fix it
using a general technique,
great technique,
called indirection.
So this is step 5, indirection.
The idea is simple.
We want to use the
previous data structure
on N over log N items.
And, well, we need to store N
items, so where do we put them?
On the bottom.
So I'm going to have theta
log N nodes down here,
theta log N nodes next to them--
or items, I should say.
Theta log N.
OK.
And then one of these items,
let's say the min item,
gets stored in this tree.
The min item over here
The min item here
gets stored up here.
OK.
So this item only--
the data structure
we just developed,
I only store N over
log N of the items.
The rest that fit in
between those items
are stored down here.
Now I use standard
B-tree tricks, actually.
If I want to do an insertion,
how do I do a search?
I follow a root to leaf path.
And then I do a linear scan
of this entire structure.
How much does it cost to
do a linear scan of log N?
Only log N divided by B. This
is smaller than log base B of N,
so the hard part of search
is the log base B of N.
OK.
How do I do an update?
Well, first, I
search for the guy.
I find the block that it
fits into and just insert
into that block.
Done.
As long as this block
doesn't get too big,
how do I insert into a block?
Rewrite the entire block.
It's a scan.
It only takes log
N over B, so it's
basically free to rewrite
this entire block every time
as long as it has size at most
log N. If it gets too full,
then I split it into two
parts that are half-full.
So in general, each
of these blocks
will maintain the size to be
between 1/4 log N and log N.
So if it gets
bigger than log N, I
split into two guys of 1/2 size.
If it gets smaller
than 1/4 log N,
then I'll merge it with
one of its neighbors
and then possibly
have to re-split it.
Or you can think of it
as stealing neighbors
from your siblings.
That's what you do in B-trees.
But with a constant number
of merges and splits,
you can restore the property
that these guys have
sizes very close to
1/2 log N. And so
if they end up getting
full, that means
you inserted 1/2 log N items.
If they ended up
getting empty, that
means you deleted
1/4 log N items.
And so in both cases, you
have log N items to charge to.
Whenever you do an
update up here--
so we update up here
every time we split
or merge down here,
because this guy has
to keep track of the blocks,
not the items in the blocks.
So we effectively
slow down the updates
in the top structure
by a factor log N,
which is great, because
we take this update bound
and we get to divide it by log
N, which removes this square.
So we end up with--
so we used to have log base B
of N plus log squared N over B.
We get to divide
that by log N, plus
we have to do this
part at the bottom.
Plus we're doing log N
over B at the bottom.
So basically, this log
cancels with this square,
so this is log N over B as well.
This thing gets even
smaller, so we end up
being able to do
updates in log N over B.
Not really though,
because at the beginning,
we have to do a search to figure
out where to do the update.
If you knew where
you had to update,
you could update
a little faster.
You could update
in log N divided
by B. If you don't
know where to update,
you've got to spend log base
B of N to search initially.
But that's the fun part.
We can now update
this data structure
fast, just with this one layer
of indirection with log N
chunks at the bottom, speeding
this data structure up
by a factor of
log N for updates.
Searches don't take any longer.
You just pay this
extra term, which
was already much smaller than
what we were paying before.
Phew.
That's cache-oblivious
B-trees, other than ordered
file maintenance, which
we'll do next class.